[Music]
this doggy a bit of paper means
everything to Alejandra and his family
every couple of moments they check it
their release there it is is so valuable
it's their number in the list the list
is a strange thing volunteers who are
migrants themselves keep it in a notepad
in the Mexican border city of Tijuana it
determines the order in which for
thousands of asylum seekers here will be
seen by US officials no one knows
exactly who started it or when but it's
evolved into a system to try and keep
order as the US has slowed up the
processing of asylum claims each day
American officials tell their Mexican
counterparts how many people they're
willing to receive and at 8 o'clock
there's an impromptu ceremony in which
the list holders announce whose number
has come up the list moves achingly
slowly migrants rights activists
estimate that there are now nine
thousand people on it but just 40 or so
are taken every day since they fled the
violent gangs battling over their native
Mitch we can
Alejandro's family have been waiting
five months for their turn wait here day
after day sometimes without anywhere to
stay with your children because there's
practically nowhere to put you up it's a
struggle at least their numbers almost
up Christian Mendoza has just signed on
and has months to go he fled Nicaragua
after he says taking a beating from
government backed paramilitaries he's
philosophical about the way I have
freedom at least that's a win because in
my country I don't have that and the
three months I have to wait to apply for
asylum are just another test that life
throws at me the system seems so
ingrained that those on the list would
never guess that it's a relatively new
arrangement the list hasn't always been
there it's something that sprung up over
the last few years before then you could
just knock straight on the door of the
United States to ask for asylum so this
is definitely another step that's been
added to the process
rights lawyers say that violates
international law that's enough let's
see then people decide where they want
to apply for asylum and should be able
to ask for that right immediately this
prerequisite to join this list doesn't
exist in any law and that's why it's
illegal and of course the list only gets
you to the point where you can request
asylum after that comes a process that
takes months if not years and for many
is unsuccessful in the meantime the list
only grows longer John Holman al Jazeera
Tijuana